hey
everybody here we are once again yes
we're not hungover from last night if
you saw last night's
almost four-hour thought that [ __ ]
went over by about an hour i didn't
i didn't realize we had gone on that
long though yeah we did
yeah i mean you know it was it was a fun
show i mean as
[ __ ] up as that is a show about like
[ __ ] war atrocities but
i mean we had some fun digressions and
fun moral discussions
and [ __ ] like some good like discussion
in the comments section
again the [ __ ] is lagging i don't know
yeah what to do about
it uh and i was uh i was clicked on to
it in the waiting section and it never
started i had to [ __ ] back out and
get back in it
yeah you had to do that before though
right i don't know what it is i don't
know why it does it other people seem to
be going in
must be you yeah your shit's messed up
thomas is in there mango badgers in
there hi guys what's up
all right now i've got seven in there
they're all piling in hi
what's up debra we're so we're so
just edified that all y'all just coming
here yes
blather every day
yeah tammy said the yesterday's show was
great yeah yeah i'm glad
i'm glad it was great i don't remember
some of the [ __ ] at the end but it's
like
[ __ ] don't i always well
actually i drank a lot more than because
usually i just have one or two on the
show i think i was on my third one by
the end of that
but weirdly i didn't um she gets
combative which she drinks sometimes
sometimes yeah she gets combative it
depends if i'm bad i
don't know how to deal with it though
i remember talking about how much it
like how much it irked me that
um when you when i put on a sweater in
my office and yeah
and you're like why are you where it's
when it's not cold in here yeah it's not
cold here
you're like 75. it's like we've got a
sweater it's not cold in here [ __ ] you
don't tell me when i'm calling
don't tell me if i'm cold or not i'm
cold that's not cold
it's 75. it's not you don't live in the
body so you don't know it's like you
know
it's not circulatory it's just not
circulatory [ __ ] i think that's what
you said
yeah you can't [ __ ] circulate
circulate that heat man circulate the
blood
well it's weird because i'm not and i
know that that's kind of like a cliche
is it like women are always cold and
stuff
i'm not i'm usually actually i'm usually
like too warm
yeah i don't like you know i don't like
being too warm
um but for some reason just in my office
is cold i don't know why
i think it's just my ex-wife is [ __ ]
all this [ __ ] cold
called us about her feet or at least
you're not about you'd never complain
about her feet
yeah she was always her feet were always
cold my it's not my feet that are cold
i'm just cold
all over but usually it's just when i'm
in my office when i'm sitting in the
bedroom or something like that it's like
usually i'm too warm out there
like my feet are cold you got three pair
of [ __ ] socks on
what's the matter with three pair of
socks on it's [ __ ] 75 degrees in here
i would rather be cold i would rather be
cold than be warm though
i really do not like being too warm all
right so
what we're going to be talking about
today is yet another
shutter exclusive this is an indonesian
movie
called impedigore yeah i like this movie
this was actually very good yeah and
it's funny because you see
in you know indonesia and you're
thinking i surprised cheap ass like a
flick
this movie's [ __ ] better than a
hollywood movie it was really beautiful
shocking
i have to say like a lot of the movies
that we've seen lately um
even though they were low budget and
stuff like that uh everybody's up in
their cinematography game because a lot
of them are like really really nice
looking movies yeah
you know and the guys who made this
movie you know they they know
kubrick and they know the shining
they've seen a lot of movies
yeah because you can see the the
influence
the influence in terms of how [ __ ] was
shot how it was filmed and it's not a
knockoff movie it
it had a lot of you know unique features
to the movie the tone was kind of unique
and it looked like a [ __ ] big budget
movie big budget hollywood movie
and they were [ __ ] hardcore skinning
people alive and they didn't really show
it
but they showed they let you know what
happened yeah they kind of showed some
of it
like the aftermath and stuff it's not
like over-the-top gory but it doesn't
shy away from gorillas
kind of like cross between the shining
some kind of movie about a curse
and then like texas chainsaw massacre
all kind of combined can i just say i
love curse movies yeah i feel
i just really like that that whole idea
this family of people out in the middle
of nowhere
[ __ ] trying to deal with this curse
and then to do it they got to skin
people
and i don't want to i don't want to like
yeah i don't i'll give like a run down
but i'm not going to like spoil it too
much
yes indonesian [ __ ] creepy ass
indonesian rednecks out in the middle of
the [ __ ]
you know how you know you know how like
in texas chainsaw massacre you got the
creepy [ __ ] hillbillies yeah
but they got indonesian versions of that
going on
yeah you look weirdos like living in
some little village out in the middle of
nowhere there's only like 100 people
living in this little [ __ ] village
and you can only get there by like a
horse-drawn carriage and [ __ ] yeah
but there's like no road a bunch of
weird-ass [ __ ] indonesian rednecks
essentially basically what i didn't
realize until
i went and did a little bit of research
about this movie
is that um the guy that made it the
director joko anwar
he actually also made satan's slaves
which is actually a remake of a very
popular uh
cult horror movie uh indonesian that
came out in the early 80s 1980 or 1982 i
believe
and i do think that satan's slaves is
also on shutter
um or it was last time i looked so i
will probably have to watch that as well
because it's the same director this guy
also did like a superhero
movie like i think last year but um came
back into
horror to do this one now
what okay so what the story is i have to
say that like
the opening you know how sometimes you
see a movie and it's like kind of a slow
like opening and you just like it kind
of takes you a while to like catch the
wave
this one did not have that problem i
think you missed the very
the beginning scene because when you
came back in i told you i was like oh
man you should have seen like the
beginning because it was like dynamite
yeah i missed like the first
30 seconds of the damn movie no you
missed more than that but it was
probably like the first five to 10.
i had to go and do something i forgot
what it was i was doing yeah i don't
remember what you were then it came back
in
it didn't matter though i still got into
it yeah you still got into it but i just
have to say like the opening sequence of
this was like
really really good i mean it really like
sucked you right into the story so
basically what happens at the very
beginning
is that there's these two girls who are
friends one of them is named maya and
one of them is named
denny and they work at like a toll booth
like they're both in like little toll
booth since i don't know if it's an
airport or
whatever it is i don't think it matters
or a parking lot and they're kind of
working there overnight and they're
complaining about how they don't have
any money and it's like this is a boring
job and [ __ ] like that they're talking
to each other over their cell phones
and then this car pulls up and
maya says to denny she's like man i've
seen this car like
all the time and i think this dude might
be stalking me or something it's like
super creepy
and you know the guy's like paying and
he's like all creepy and everything and
she's like oh man what the [ __ ] this is
like really [ __ ] up
and he just like looks like he's gonna
lurk and stay there and then finally
this other truck comes and he
you think that he's kind of scared away
and she's like oh you know she's all
relieved and [ __ ]
but then after the truck leaves then she
kind of looks out the window and the car
is still over there and then the guy
gets out of the car and then he starts
like coming toward and he's like
attacking her and he starts saying like
all this really weird [ __ ] like um
he says something about we don't want
what your family left behind
that's what he says and he starts like
attacking her so it's like it's really
really good
like compelling opening yeah and don't
and i say that they're
indonesian [ __ ] rednecks like that
it's not so over the top like texas
chainsaw massacre
or devil's rejects we're not talking
about that yeah it's not like this is a
very
time it's serious it's not funny creepy
ass country people
and you can't figure out what the [ __ ]
they're doing you know but you'll see
yeah it's like a mystery because so
basically what ends up happening i mean
the only funny thing in it is that the
friend denny
is actually kind of like a wise ass um
you know what i mean which i kind of
liked i like kind of liked her character
because maya was like a little bit more
um serious so they figure out they're
like well
maya didn't know who her parents were i
guess she'd been raised by an aunt
so she kind of delves a little into her
history and she finds out that her
parents are from like this little bitty
town like out in bum [ __ ] nowhere
and that they might have been wealthy
and that they might have owned a house
out there and that might she might like
inherit it
so her and her friend decide to go out
to the village just you know check it
out and see it's like hey maybe we've
got a big inheritance coming or whatever
so they go out to this village which
like i said is out in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere
you can't even like there's not even
really a road it's just like a dirt road
out to it
and so they get to this village and they
don't want to say like who they are so
they just like say that they're students
like anthropology students or something
and they're like
you know studying because the one guy
that's like the the head of the village
does this uh ancient shadow puppetry
thing they have a name for it but i
can't remember what it is
and um so they say that they're there
studying that and they heard that this
guy was the best or whatever
so when they get there like everybody's
acting like super sketch and then
there's like all of these graves that
appear to be children and there are like
no children running around in the
village which they think is a little
creepy and um so the mystery kind of
evolves from there it's like who
her parents were like what ended up
happening in this village um you know
how
there's maybe a curse and how you know
maybe some people get skinned along the
way and
various things happen of that nature but
yeah
this is just like a really i mean other
that that really great
opening is just like so it just like
sucks you right into the story
and then it kind of like pulls back a
little bit and like kind of goes more
into like a slow burn kind of mode but
like
creepy and like it's just like amping up
the mystery as they're like getting to
this town and you're like what the [ __ ]
is the deal with everybody
the tone for me was kind of kind of like
the shiny that's what it was
that's kind of what the tone it did have
a bit of that it did it had some scenes
where it went a little more over the top
than what the shining does like you know
there's some special effects scenes
and of course there's some kind of gore
and stuff that
but there was something about it that
kind of they were trying to be kind of
kubrickian like
that's yeah that's the way it felt to me
although
not not all the way yeah i could tell
that there was an influence there
and it was more it didn't have like the
chilliness i guess of a kubrick movie
it was more like it was a lot of like
warmth because it's very it's very
yellow and red and it had like a lot of
warm
some about kubrick though man that kind
of like you said that cold clinical
feeling to it man
i liked it i do too like i i can see
i understand how some people might think
it's off-putting but i don't find it
very off-putting
no um you know i think it's pretty cool
yeah it's like you know
everyone's mileage may vary and and i
get what people are saying when they say
because a lot of people say the same
thing i think we talked about this
before about uh david cronenberg
um but i don't really yeah i like that
too
does i don't it doesn't bother me it
doesn't make it so that i can't
emotionally connect with the characters
or anything like that
so i mean maybe it does for some people
the cronenberg stuff is supposed to make
you feel slightly alienated
from the movie yeah that's kind of what
it and i feel like i mean
cronenberg in particular he's not
particularly interested
in i feel like he's not really
interested in an emotional
connection with the characters like you
said he's trying to isolate us
from the people in the movie are trying
to isolate the people in the movie from
each other
so you get that kind of sense of
alienation whereas kubrick i think
kind of gets [ __ ] on for that but i
don't really think that that's what he
was
what he's doing you know what i'm saying
yeah because i mean look at the shining
look at wendy's character who's like
super the top emotional
and you know and you feel for her you
can you know what most people do and
you have an emotional connection with so
i don't feel like
you know i don't feel that kind of like
disconnection at all we're going into
other directors though we got to stay on
this movie
yeah i know but this movie here we can't
really say a whole lot about it because
they don't want to spoil it yeah i don't
want to spoil it because i definitely
think the movie yeah i definitely do
feel like um
i guess this premiered last year i guess
at a film festival like a lot of these
do um and it just came to
shutter like a few days ago yeah and
like i said they have
another one of his movies uh satan
slaves which is a remake slash
prequel from what i could gather so now
that i've seen this one
i actually kind of want to go back and
see that one because i haven't watched
that one yet i didn't realize it was the
same director
but i mean look at all the cool [ __ ]
i mean shutters really good for having
classics and for having new stuff they
have a lot of really good foreign horror
too
and we've seen a lot of really good
foreign horror on there like you know
the pool which was the thai one that we
reviewed the other day which i
that was fun which i really loved i
thought that was fantastic and this one
is like
you know not like a monster movie this
one's more like a creepy
like slow burn curse type thing um so
it's not exactly the same as that but i
mean
just the cinematography is gorgeous um
you know the you know the imagery like
it has like really creepy
like imagery like i said not over the
top gory but it doesn't like
shy away from it either like i feel like
a lot of it's done through implication
yeah i just think it's [ __ ] hilarious
what the apocalypse is like i mean you
know [ __ ] the major theater chains
[ __ ] collapse and everything going
on [ __ ] you know stream on demand all
these [ __ ]
new services like shutter i [ __ ] love
it
and then it allows you to [ __ ] see
movies from the other side of the world
and you have a developing nation like
like [ __ ] indonesia
normally you would associate that with
some [ __ ] crappy ass films back in
the 70s and the 80s like i don't want to
see that [ __ ]
but now they [ __ ] can technology is
everywhere and everybody
everybody sees what everybody else is
doing and they know who
you know what good film looked like and
bam indonesia can [ __ ] bring it i
mean that is what
this movie looked like it looked like a
top-notch hollywood flick
yeah you would never know like if it was
you know if you could somehow dub it
into english without anybody realizing
that it was dubbed into english you
would never know
yeah that it was like from a foreign
country or anything like that it wasn't
like
everybody has high technology now that's
access to it well that's like
that is the best thing one of the best
things to come out of the internet and
to come out of like all this technology
being
really cheap and really accessible to
everybody is now you're getting
in some ways you almost have the
opposite problem where now there's like
too much
too much good stuff like the way through
it's like i have stacks of movies that i
still have to watch i have stacks of
books i still want to read
i just have like stacks of stuff that i
want to get to and i just feel like i
will never have time what [ __ ] up
hollywood hollywood got
[ __ ] up in a couple different ways the
first wave was like in the 70s you had
these tired old [ __ ] crusty directors
they only wanted to do cop flicks and
[ __ ] all right and westerns
you know and they had a very formula
way of doing things for these studios
and then a new wave came
that was like spielberg and lucas and
all these guys and they were kind of the
independent dudes
and and they took over well
now they're kind of aging out and then
the new guys that are coming in i just
don't find him to be talented
it used to be that hollywood kind of had
a monopoly on
on the technology you needed to make a
badass movie
and they kind of cornered the market on
that for a while now everybody has it
yes so now it's survival of the fittest
it's now
well it's democratized now it's not now
the tama
the exactly the technology is
democratized
and now it's sink or swim
natural selection survival of the
fittest a
a good talented young director and good
writers
can get their hands on the technology
you need to make a [ __ ] film
that could blow a [ __ ] hollywood
studio away
and i mean like i said if they can get
it to a festival or they can get it to a
streaming service like millions of
people can see it which that's just
amazing that's unprecedented i don't
like hollywood i'm not a fan of [ __ ]
hollywood right now mostly because
they're [ __ ] shutting off creativity
they're blocking create they're trying
to act like a gatekeeper like it's
[ __ ] 1970s and 1980s
and they're you know what i mean and and
they're limiting
they're limiting their own it's a racket
that's what it is it's racketized
you know they're gonna say oh we're
gonna make this movie this movie and
this movie and you can't touch it and i
just don't like that [ __ ]
it's not creative it's too corporate
yeah but now
now that corporate [ __ ] is not going
to survive
you have to be creative to make a a good
movie now it's just the way it's going
to be
yeah well that's okay yeah that's good
for us as viewers
yeah we have now have access like i said
i have just i have a huge
list i wrote a huge list of like all the
[ __ ] that i want to watch and yeah and
new stuff comes out all the time
so it's like um i wanted to address like
thomas carlisle says the great sci-fi
horror on netflix called the endless i
have actually seen that that is
fantastic uh it's kind of a
cosmic horror a little bit i haven't
seen it um yeah i really really liked it
um
i kind of reminded me a little bit of
the void but not
quite you know i mean the void was more
like a monster movie this one was more
like
cosmic horror in like the old school
sense um but yeah that was like really
good so yeah if you guys haven't seen
that one that
is one i would definitely recommend i
mean [ __ ] man i was talking about this
on the show last night but one thing i'm
thinking about doing
is either starting on halloween or
starting uh
at the beginning of next year i want to
start doing like maybe a weekly or
bi-weekly
like book review like horror books
mostly new ones but old ones as well
so it's like i ordered like a whole
bunch and i have like kindle unlimited
like subscription so it's like there's
books on there i can read
so i have a huge list already of almost
a year's worth of
shows okay so i like that i like how
it's going
i don't like these hollywood [ __ ]
executives blocking me from seeing [ __ ]
that i want to see
back in the old world there never would
have been say like blood machines
how cool that was yeah that's a cool
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] cool flick you
know what i mean and that could have
never
that could have never come about without
the democratization of all this
technology
and this new survival of the fittest
[ __ ] mentality you know i mean which
that's what has to happen
yeah no more gatekeepers i mean and like
i said you know you're gonna get a glo
of [ __ ] also yeah [ __ ] but that [ __ ] was
already there
the [ __ ] was already there and that was
the same thing that happened
like um you know when punk got big like
in the 70s when it got cheaper to like
record your own music
you know there was a lot of good [ __ ]
but there was a lot of crappy [ __ ] a lot
of crappy [ __ ]
but it's gone that's forgotten and this
yeah and that's kind of the same
what will happen yes there's like a lot
of [ __ ] that comes out but
that's kind of true of any era the good
stuff will some of this [ __ ] that's
coming out though
is better than this than a lot of the
so-called good expensive stuff
like remember the one what was the one
with the [ __ ] the shark
one no no velocity philosopher was
[ __ ] hilarious
and that was i loved it so much it was
good writing
it was good writing and they understood
the genre kung fu
dinosaurs and [ __ ] with ninjas i mean
you can't go wrong yeah and then just
the [ __ ] ironic way it was shot
like i said they leaned into exactly
what they were doing i mean we did watch
like other like we watched ouija shark
and we reviewed that um we started
we started watching shark exorcist but i
just didn't get through it
because that's the thing it's like
there's a lot of those shitty movies and
they're fun
oh my gosh thank you very much mango
badger thank you very much man
um you know and they're fun to watch but
some of them like it's just like a
couple fun scenes and then the rest of
it's filler
philosophy is not like no you guys want
to see if you like
if you like 80s kung fu flicks action
flicks and like the real cheap [ __ ] you
know what i mean if you're into the
[ __ ] kubate and everything
you got to see velocipaster because they
i really love it yeah and it's on to be
for free
we were just talking about that
beforehand because one of the next uh
movie retrospectives we're gonna do the
last movie respected we did ninth
configuration the william peter bladder
blatty movie was also on tv for free
and the one we're gonna do this week is
also on to be for free
uh the thing about 2b is they have
a metric fuckton of horror movies
which is great yeah um but there's a lot
of [ __ ] on there yeah so you really kind
of have to know but then the thing
but then there's like really good [ __ ]
on there too like like [ __ ] uh
triangle is on there which is a
fantastic kind of mind [ __ ] kind of
movie
so there's like all this really good
[ __ ] on there but you really have to
know
what you're looking for that's why i
kind of go to like videos and lists and
be like you know what's the best horror
movies on 2b right now so i have to
scroll through like 40 bajillion
you know shark exorcists to get to
something good
because you know there's so many it's
like you don't know like which ones are
good and which ones are gonna suck it's
kind of hard to tell
mango badger his his shirt got shipped
out didn't it not yet because i don't
have the size or the address
okay i don't have the size of the
address all right yes but i have a size
or an address
you're gonna get some shirts i will send
you some shirts yeah he's uk
mango badger yes send us send jenny a
private message on facebook
yeah that is probably the best what size
you want
and i'm going to send you a couple
shirts yeah all right because we got we
got a piece i'll give you that
you want bailout i sent i'll send you um
we'll send you a 13 o'clock one because
he doesn't have one of those coming does
he
no because like i said i have i don't
have the sizes or the okay watch columns
i'll uh send you a 13 o'clock one or
i'll send you
a snake pliskin one on top of that give
you i'll give you a choice between snake
pliskin
or weyland yutani so you can see i got a
whale and yutani one
it's got 13 o'clock on it also in the
back yeah on the back so
either this one or a snake piston yeah
thomas carlos says i don't think 2b
works in the uk i was wondering about
that because i
kind of feel like which is that's kind
of a shame because
i mean they don't just have a [ __ ] ton
of horror movies they have a [ __ ] ton of
everything tv shows like all kind of
different documentaries yeah all the
gordon ramsay cult movies yeah
they have all the pretty much every
gordon ramsay show like uk kitchen
nightmares u.s kitchen nightmares the
f-word
yeah all of them like pretty healthy
kitchens
um like all of his shows they have on
there and it's like they just have tons
of series tons of [ __ ] like that
and it's like you have to watch
commercials but not that many it's like
usually just a short commercial break at
the beginning and then
you know they'd be one every like half
an hour or something it's just like one
or two commercials
so big that's why yeah that's why he's
asking me earlier on
if uh he was asking me if if there was
an indonesian trump
i think he was because i was saying that
indonesia that had written about the
movie was about indonesian rednecks
trump is not a redneck trump is a is a
yankee he's from up north
we revoked his redneck privileges you
can't
you can't be a redneck unless you're
from the south
yeah well you can try to be one they
have red
they have redneck equivalents in other
nations though yeah like they're just
not called the same thing
it's different though a northern redneck
would be because would be called a
hillbilly
that's a hillbilly yeah all right we
don't have hillbillies in the south
that's up in the door well an out west i
kind of feel like they call them
hillbillies out well well like hills
have eyes that's not what we call them
we called them um some from k you know
when i was in california we called them
hicks
yeah yeah yeah but i think hicks are
gone now
because i think california is [ __ ]
filled packed full
i don't think there are any yeah up
north there's probably country areas of
california
but i don't think the original
inhabitants are there anymore i think
all the hicks had moved away prior went
to [ __ ] oklahoma or something
yeah mango badger saying i've been
watching shutter and the amount of
classic horror is amazing i have heard
and i don't know if it's improved uh
since then
but i've heard that shutter uk doesn't
have as many and doesn't have the same
movies as shutter us because it didn't
it didn't like last i heard because i
did hear some like uk people like
bitching about it it's like oh well you
know that's not on ours or it's like you
know
we don't have many weeks back somebody
said that or a few months back
somebody said oh they finally added a
bunch of stuff to it and i think
and i'm not sure if this will work but
if you have a vpn you can probably watch
any shutter from any country
in the world same with netflix because
that's the thing like sometimes netflix
uk
has stuff that we don't have and vice
versa but i think if you get a vpn you
can watch whatever countries netflix you
want so
yeah vpn would also get you into tubie i
would imagine yeah it should
um you know and shutter too like i said
i don't know because i know that
there's a uk version of shutter there's
a uk version of netflix i don't know if
there's a uk version of 2b
you know what i'm saying 2b is like the
internet equivalent of the [ __ ] local
dime store video
vhs rentals like where you go to watch
the [ __ ]
worst possible [ __ ] vhs movies when
you were a kid remember remember that
yeah those like sub blockbuster it's
like the [ __ ] that [ __ ] name
there's yeah it was gone from
blockbuster but you still want to see it
there's a lot of
kind of sub asylum knockoff stuff like
uh you know shark kano and like all that
kind of [ __ ]
there's a lot of that on there yeah um
but like i said
yeah some of it's unwatchable because
it's like somebody just made it on their
iphone or whatever but it's like
you really have to look and you really
have to curate the [ __ ] because there's
a ton of good [ __ ] on there too i mean
there's
like a ton of classic [ __ ] on there too
like the original suspiria is on there
like some other berry or magento
there's like so you really have to kind
of
wade through and separate the wheat from
the chaff because there actually really
is a lot of good stuff on there but
there's so much other stuff that you
have to like dig through that's the
asylum flick was [ __ ] nazis at the
center of the earth you guys got to see
that one
i think i've recommended it many times i
did really really nice
at the center of the year that's the
[ __ ] was that other one that was kind
of similar was frankenstein's army
yeah that was kind of similar that
wasn't asylum though
no that's true yeah i get confused
because since asylum was so
popular like and making so much money um
i feel like now
every like really small studio is trying
to do the same thing
yeah where it's like well you know look
what happens like ouija shark where they
were just
kind of like well everybody makes ouija
ouija board movies and everybody makes
shark movies so we're gonna like match
that [ __ ] up
and so i kind of feel like that's what
that's what all these smaller studios
are trying to do like they're trying to
catch the wave of like the next asylum
i think they have like a hat and then
they write down [ __ ] like
tarantula and you know lava flow and
they
write down like natural disasters and
animals and [ __ ] and just put it all in
a hat and then they just pick them out
and make a movie the best thing
that the best thing about nazis at the
center of the earth is that
it was true to
german science fiction of the 20s and
the 30s
that's that yeah that was in that had
influenced the nazis and
all the other stuff that all the nazi
science fiction
lore that happened after the nazis you
know like the nazi bell
i think that was kind of in there yeah
everything they knew whoever wrote that
movie
they knew that they knew their [ __ ] they
knew the [ __ ] very well
they knew about frill they knew about
hollow earth stuff
you know you know the thrill the coming
race that book
they you know which with the nazis
really liked that book
evidently yeah and um so
yeah it i would call it it is a science
fiction
horror fantasy adventure but it's also
kind of authentic yeah in a way
the nazis would have liked it probably
yeah
plus it's bat [ __ ] insane [ __ ] insane
yeah
in the best possible way but yeah so
if you have shutter i don't know if this
movie is on shutter uk but it's
definitely on
shutter us it's called impedigore
and it's an indonesian movie and it's
really good like i really
recommend it if you're into foreign
horror
uh check out the pool too we've reviewed
that one as i like that one a lot that
was a time movie
but yeah so uh we'll probably stream
again tomorrow probably do another
movie review i'm gonna look for
something else new
to watch this evening that we can review
tomorrow
and i think i have to put the audio up
of the show that we did last night too
i think i forgot to do that i wanted to
do that today too so i'll get to that in
a little while
what's on shutter uk somebody's saying
something's on shutter speed it is on
shutter uk
this movie okay yeah i wasn't sure
because like i said i know that
sometimes we say it's on shutter and
people need it was like well it's not on
shutter over here
but yeah so yeah definitely check it out
and uh
and mango badger send us a [ __ ] pm
yeah so
it's yeah just through the 13 o'clock or
you know or through tom's thing or my
thing or whatever just send us
what sizes you want and what what design
and when you need
a dress yeah which is which and we will
send
this stuff out okay probably because
like i said i have three more
shirts that have to go out and so we'll
do another mailing sometime this week
yeah and then another print yeah so uh
we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow thanks everybody for
dropping by thanks everybody who
contributed
we love you guys